we've actually done a quite a good job
throughout history we've come close to
creating apocalypses we've created the
atomic bombs of all different types but
we also have created atomic energy we've
created astronomical travel to the Stars
we've created a laser the merer the MRI
the Cat Skin physics can do great good
the question is how do we make it
resilient by building into our systems a
more close connection to physical
reality hi folks Canadian prepper here
it's an honor today to have on the
channel Dr Brian keing he's a world
renowned cosmologist who just missed the
Nobel Prize by a hair apparently he's
been on Lex fredman Jordan Peterson Ben
Shapiro meu Kaku the Weinstein Brothers
Neil the grass Tyson the list goes on
and on it's an honor to have you here
today cuz I'm always looking for
alternate perspectives on this whole
preparedness thing and I'm hoping that
we can get into a conversation about the
existential crises that might befall
humankind talk about esqu ology End Time
stuff from a physicist perspective and
you are no stranger to the internet
there's you have your own YouTube
channel who I would encourage people to
go and check out uh especially if you
like rumination on extraterrestrial
beings among other things uh this is
something we don't typically talk about
on the channel but I think we might even
do a little alien talk today which I'm
totally fine with because I got a
world-renowned physicist here the best
this is not the guy with the crazy hair
on the History Channel okay this is the
real deal guys so I'm really looking
forward this thanks for coming on yeah
well my kids give me a lot of experience
with dark matter and uh they wouldn't
let me miss the uh the father of the
Roblox prepper uh just incredible I have
the PAW Patrol prepper here in San Diego
she loves your content she loves your
son and your daughter so thank you uh
for having me on it's my my second
Canadian podcast host of this of this
month after Jordan your Countryman
Jordan so it's an honor to be in the
same league as uh as the two of you
that's a hard act to how could I follow
Jordan Peterson I mean come on it's a
Canadian prepper here so we're going to
we're going to bring it down just a
little bit I think in terms of the
intellectualizing but I I just want to
ask you okay so like as a father you
know obviously you've been watching the
channel apparently for a while but I
want to know are you bullish or bearish
about Humanity's prospects and on a
scale of 1 to 10 uh 10 being certain
near-term human extinction one being
total Utopia sunshine and rainbows where
do you think we fall right now yeah
that's an excellent question so what I
love about your channel for a long time
it's it's it's been focused not only on
what to do but what not to do and as a
father and as a scientist as a man of
science I'm caught in this ambiguity of
not knowing where the future will take
us but wanting to be prepared and the
hardest thing in life is to be in the
middle and that doesn't mean to think of
you know everything's Sunshine roses
half the time and then everything's Doom
and Gloom half the time it's knowing
what to pay attention to and what to
ignore so for example we have the
imminent threat of potential nuclear
Annihilation happening right now
suspended on top of an overlay of a
global pandemic I mean if you thought in
2014 when you started the channel in
Earnest those initial not cringeworthy
moments compared to my channels like
current Genesis of my channel okay man
uh but if you go back to those time and
you said like look man you got to get
ready there's going to be a global
pandemic there's going to be legitimate
chance of nuclear Holocaust there's
going to be tensions in the Middle East
there's going to be oil crisis there's
going to be accelerating global climate
change there's going to all these things
you'd be like well I'm gonna have like
20 million subscribers but you know that
would probably be your first thought it
would be I'm gonna just prep for the
future now conversely if I take you back
50 years and I tell you all this is
going to happen probably not that much
different you wouldn't you wouldn't like
reorient your life and you know go into
hiding right then um in fact probably if
you gave any human being of the hundred
we think that there have been a hundred
billion people that have lived in the
span of homo sapiens on this Little Rock
of a planet if you ask them would you
like to live now or when you lived uh
the preponderance of people would say
right now you know plus or minus a few
years so I I think it's a golden age
it's the best of times it's the worst of
times it it has the potential for this
this very annoying aspect for the human
mind which is ambiguity we just don't
know it's like Schrodinger's cat is it
alive is it dead we can agree on things
we can disagree on things here in
America we have the Second Amendment um
which which we take advantage of uh but
we don't think we should have a portable
thermonuclear you know harar 2 system in
our house um uh even reasonable people
you know who are gun toing members of
the NRA would agree to that conversely
we believe you know in in a right to
choose but we don't believe like you
should have abortion the day of uh the
birth of a baby and that's why there are
so much polarization because we try to
find what the answer is we try to
predict we try to throw out alternative
uh uh consequences and just focus on one
so right now I'm I'm kind of shortterm
nervous long-term very optimistic about
the state of humanity yeah that's good I
mean part of the reason why I got into
preparedness in the first place was
there is a overall optimistic bias
towards the future that present in our
society some people might call it the
normaly bias so in in order to kind of
counterbalance that the almost need to
go in the other direction and somebody's
got to be the guy in the room saying hey
this can go wrong this can go wrong this
can go wrong so it doesn't inevitably go
there so you almost need to stoke the
fires of that every so often with maybe
a little bit of alarmism to get the
conversation going which is why you know
there's people like G mcferson who's
very climate dooming Gloom I don't agree
with his prognosticating about the
environment and how you know things are
going to collapse by 2030 but I think it
gets people talking so there's there's
potentially a value to it in that
respect but you know uh there's
different uh you know conflicting views
on whether or not that's useful I think
one of the things is that if you're
contrarian you sound smart I mean you
only have to be right you know once to
have uh you know to have basically a
career you've had on I've had on Peter
Schiff you know on our podcast uh had
him on to talk about the virtues of
Bitcoin uh which he refused to do uh but
we talked about you know these
predictions that he made back in 200 six
and seven and he was right and and now
the question is he right about
everything else well you get make can
make a career out of this in science
though it's very different you can only
be wrong once if you make a mistake in
science your credibility is on the line
and you can do that you can get away
with that and we'll talk about famous
examples of that and it's actually one
of the most pernicious and and
diabolical forces in all of all of
science right now is the Reliance of the
public on science has never been more
but the Public's understanding of
science has never been less so how do
you you know kind of balance the Sila
and the caribas together it's very
precarious position that we're on I mean
we control the powers of the atom the
powers of the cell the nucleus and and
what can we do with it is kind of
limited by by sober heads prevailing and
we missed Destruction come very close to
destruction many times you categorize
this on the channel many times uh but
what I'm what I'm worried about is that
the the polarization does seem sort of
you know irrevocable like we we only
seem to go in One Direction I have yet
to see um the the the ratchet move the
other direction and maybe that's because
it can't because the human mind is wired
towards contrarianism towards Cassandra
ISM and so forth but we have to always
maintain this optimistic positive bias
not be polyana but always maintain the
bias that humans are capable of this
magical you know future but only if we
act you know soberly and rationally
problem is you know the leadership is
really just not taking us there uh in
one of your recent conversations with
Eric Weinstein um he had said that he
thought that we are on borrowed time and
it was just kind of a passing comment
that he made but it was in reference to
the incompetence of our leadership now
do you uh share that sentiment or do you
have faith in their ability to mitigate
some of these issues that we face or do
you think that you know where we have to
go through a great Reckoning first I
want to First pledge my allegiance to
CLA Schwab Nate as you know we have to
always have our Allegiance uh Clear and
Present um I I took down my Shrine
before the video started so yeah yeah
you've got your trudos on so you so
here's an interesting contrast so Eric
when he had that conversation with me uh
it was you know a dire warning to
humanity and and he's love you know I
love him for his Rants and and I get to
hear some of them over a bottle of Scot
watching the cigar that that the general
Public's not privy to but the point I
think he's trying to make is we have an
80-year-old president and just take you
know not not not being Democrat or you
know Republican I always say look I
became an astronomer because there's no
Republican constellation there's no
Democratic asteroid you know there there
they different you know kind of
procedures that that both parties might
adhere to you know climate change versus
you know economic benefit but look let's
look at Biden he's 80 years old take an
80-year old American male what's his
life EXP expectancy it's only six years
uh and that's an average figure that
means in any given year he has like an
8% chance of dying you just take you
know 92% to the eighth power and and you
see what that's going to come out to be
and that's about 50% or so if I do the
math in my head the point being that
he's very likely to die he's much more
likely to die and he should live and be
well and and I you know I'm not a huge
supporter of him uh and and the way that
he is kind of polarized uh not not just
not just you know politics is natural
for a politician nowadays but science
and and and making dire predictions that
encroach upon uh the domain that I'm an
expert in but let let's leave that aside
uh but the point being you can't just
say well because Biden's old he
shouldn't be president we're in great
danger uh you have a very young leader
in your country a very uh very you know
kind of handsome man who I think is
clone of my governor who's also my boss
Gavin Newsome here very handsome uh he
doesn't he has a you know 05% chance of
dying in any given year so the point
being you can't necessarily rely on the
the the kind of intrinsic qualities of a
particular candidate you have to think
about the systems that support them so
what is the bias of our system is it
resilient to perturbations we ask a
question if you have a marble you know
and you take a bowl and you put the bowl
upside down you put the marble on top
you move it a little bit it will
actually be stable at the very top but
the smallest pertubation will send that
kening off into Oblivion likewise if you
invert the bowl and put the marble the
bottom it'll stay there all day uh so
the point being how resilient is the
architecture that supports the
technology the society the military I
have a huge number of people that that
are in the military and my family and
and and my audience I know you you do as
well the the point being they are
incredibly resilient and I once heard it
said by um I think it was it wasn't a GU
oh yes it was a guest his name is David
marqu spelled marquet he's a commander
of the USS Santa Fe which was the worst
performing nuclear-powered submarine
with nuclear tipped missiles in the
whole United States Navy and and he
turned it around from worst to First and
he has a book called turn the ship
around it's a great book on leadership
and people always ask me why are you
like reading books on leadership you're
an astrophysicist well I'm not
one-dimensional I contain multitudes I
love to learn different things I watch
about prepping and I watch about String
Theory okay these are the most and I
talk about these things on my channel
too which gives me an outlet for my
otherwise narcissistic behavior but the
point being David marquay commander in
the US Navy said if Joe Biden wants to
kill somebody it takes about 20
different phone calls and 14 different
organizations before a guy in a wire
who's a dangerous violent man will pull
that trigger and off somebody and it's a
good thing that we have those systems
it's a good thing that we have these
resilient systems um they've come close
to breaking down the past though so we
have to ask ourselves what can we do to
build in systems at the base layer of
reality which is physics and I think
there's a whole lot of opport
opportunity for us in the physical
sciences that we normally sh because we
like to be in our comfortable white
Ivory Towers and and and speculate about
things that are completely esoteric and
in some cases quite meaningless but we
have an obligation and we've actually
done a quite a good job throughout
history we've come close to creating
apocalypses because we we've uh
molecular biology which is the science
behind you know viral manipulation
crisper that came out of physics that
another name for for molecular biology
is biological physics uh Watson and
Crick were physicists rosin Franklin was
a physicist so we've been in the DNA
field we've been obviously in the
nuclear realm we've created the atomic
bombs of all different types but we also
have created atomic energy we've created
uh astronomical travel to the Stars
we've created a laser the merer the MRI
the Cat Skin physics can do great good
and the question is how do we make it
resilient by building into our systems a
more close connection to physical
reality and and I hope we can talk about
some of that today hey friends just a
short request to ask you to use your
thumb while my thumb is occupied to
leave a like on this video and don't
forget to subscribe it really helps us
with the algorithm now back to the
episode technology is definitely a
double-edged sword now as a cosmologist
you're always talking about and a lot of
your work focuses around what happened
at the big bang you know how far does
our ignorance go back type thing um
there seems to be this Obsession within
Society with end times uh whether it's
just the psychology of the Alpha and the
Omega and rightly so because you know
I've been listening to a lot of I've
been on this Terrence mckenic kick and
he says one of the most
absurd things in science is at its core
this idea that something just manifested
out of nothing like the idea is so
incredibly absurd but it's like the
basis of all scientific inquiry yet
we're told you know that all the belief
in God is silly or you know it's not
scientific or rational yet at that one
fundamental belief but I mean maybe
that's just another uh question
altogether but why do you think there's
this fascination with the end and maybe
in your case the beginning the Alpha and
the Omega yeah that's a that's a
wonderful question so I always ask
people you know what's the most
important day on the calendar now don't
don't tell me because it's personal
information I'm sure but what what kind
of day is most important to you most
memorable to You Ah that's a good
question I'm I'm
pretty before we started this I we
talked about the we should have metric
time because I'm not a person who puts
great significance in terms of days in
terms of uh you know I guess you know
for my kids it would be Christmas or
something you know right okay so
Christmas what's Christmas by the way I
I think you just proved without
admitting it that your wife doesn't
watch your channel very much because you
know if you were smarter than you know
than me you might say my anniversary
I'm not going to hold that against you
so so honey you know I would say my
anniversary but we're pretty
unconventional like that but yeah okay
so you are very good very good so um
most people will say Christmas new
years's my birthday my wife's birthday
anniversary kids birthdays etc etc what
are those those are Beginnings they
Fascinate us because they're the only
event that you really weren't around for
and it happens to be you get a reminder
every year right the Earth orbits around
the Sun once per year so we come back to
the same place although not really it's
kind of interesting to think about what
it actually does but be that as it may
it's a beginning and your own personal
beginning you did not witness okay
there's even if you have video it's it's
not really the same thing and I don't
want to watch those videos anyway the
point being humans are fascinated with
this because in principle the origin of
the universe is a time before which
there were no yesterdays and that's a
mind-blowing concept so when we think
about time we think about time in very
very few concrete ways that we can
really understand and some people say
time is not real it's an emergent
phenomena and that that means it is not
individually definable anymore than the
temperature of a single oxygen molecule
in this room is definable it's only
definable with respect to the collective
Ensemble behavior in which it's part of
so so too is the universe when we
consider time so what happened before
let's say there is a moment of time and
I would say there's a preponderance of
cosm olist and others that believe that
there was a true beginning of time some
people say that's the big bang that's
not technically correct the Big Bang
could be just quote unquote a big uh
doing a lot of heavy lifting with these
quotes but the big bang could be just
the beginning of our observable universe
or it could be just the beginning of the
matter that makes up our observable
universe or it could be the Endo of a
previous universe but if it is the
beginning true beginning of not only our
observable universe in the matter within
it but of itself question is what
happened you know the Tuesday before
that does that even make sense so these
are mindbending Concepts that really
reckon with what normal people with
present company excluded are fascinated
by time because time is so difficult and
Squishy to pin down that we have a
multitude of different ways to Define it
which is not true of most other
quantities right if you if you talk
about measuring mass you can you can
determine what the mass is in different
ways you guys use kilograms where where
we're much you know wiser we use pounds
down here um but intrinsically there's
only a finite number of atoms you can
count those atoms right so the point
being that's an extrinsic type of
measurement you can't you can't redefine
it but time is not like that so it plays
gimmicks with the human mind and so we
become very fascinated with it on the
other hand in the Deep future there's a
similar question what will happen to our
universe in the very very far future
will it go on forever is it part of an
unending series of Cycles
is it part of a new universe which will
emerge in What's called the Multiverse
which is all the rage in cosmology
nowadays these are questions and what
makes them so delightful aside from
getting paid to answer them or tried to
try to answer them building experimental
tools unlike my friend Neil degrass
Tyson that you mentioned and others he
doesn't you he doesn't build telescopes
he he looks at data that has come in
from other telescopes or Mitch okaku or
others they don't they don't actually
build the hardware that gathers the data
that Reon with the claims made by people
much brighter than I am to as to what is
the nature of the base layer of physical
reality and then there are some Nate who
say that we can manipulate space and
time if only we understood the ultimate
building blocks of Nature and how the
laws of nature via their symmetries and
Via their properties are either
Universal or can be modified melded and
contorted to potentially suit our needs
as technological beings as Preppers and
so forth so I I think it's a fascinating
thing and it's it's delightful to be
able to get paid you know all man a
public university but I get paid to do
this and I I just want to be an
evangelist for other young people that
care about big picture topics philosophy
this is a job that enables you to
Grapple with what I think me it means to
be a human being and ask questions that
only the human mind is capable of now
there's this thing called the cardish
scale and I don't know how much stock
you put in this Theory but I think it
might be a good place to start for our
conversation because you know it's this
idea that there's these type zero type
one and maybe type two civiliz I
shouldn't even know like the the scale
but the idea that there's this great
filter that typically species will
destroy themselves with the technology
that they create before they can lift
off and Traverse the cosmos can you
explain what you know these type
civilizations are and whether you think
we are a type one civilization so so
there's only one immutable law of
physics all other laws are basically
provisional and subject to to potential
uh revision and that's that energy is
conserved not matter matter is not
conserved we can destroy matter we can
create matter um from Pure Energy but
you can't create or destroy energy and
it's deeply ingrained in What's called
the laws of
thermodynamics uh which are a construct
of the physical uh universe that was
discovered when things that are
practical like steam engines and and so
forth came to be uh in the in the
industrial revolution and pre-industrial
Revolution because people started to
notice there was a connection between
heat energy temperature pressure volume
and all these different variables and so
they became obsessed with characterizing
these things and lucky for them those
laws are really as I said inviolable
unlike say the law of gravity from Isaac
Newton uh which which held that you know
gravity propagates throughout the
Universe faster than the speed of light
you know infinitely fast that was
provisional that was revised by Albert
Einstein and yet and yet we still use
the laws of Newton to get the Starship
into orbit hopefully eventually get the
Landers on the moon in a couple of years
again and so forth so what the kardashev
scale is attempting to tap into and it's
not something that we practicing
physicists you know make use of although
it does connect with the very first
guest I ever had on my podcast Nate
which is a man by the name of Freeman
Dyson not the Dyson vacuum guy although
I did get a picture of him once with a
vacuum he's passed away he passed away
right after Co began in 2020 94 years
old wonderful man and he was the first
guest on my podcast into the impossible
and we used to talk about these things
called Dyson spheres well what is a
Dyson Sphere a Dyson Sphere couples to
the Cerf scale in the following way the
CF scale attempts to classify the
different levels that a civilization's
technology could achieve which would be
driven by the most fundamental inviable
quantity in all of the universe which I
said is energy so how much energy is
available to a particular planet or
particular civilization so this guy
kardashev um talked about how you could
actually harness this energy now the
energy can come in many different forms
but it uh it was classified according to
the laws that were available back then
in other words uh solar energy
thermonuclear energy Etc there may be
other forms of energy that we don't have
access to or can't tap into in that case
this cardash shf scale is also
provisional as I said so a type one
civilization has harnessed all of the
energy that is available on its home
planet so we do believe that if you live
on say a water world or something like
that there' be no way to really harness
that energy I always say you know to get
where we are today to have this
conversation at the speed of light over
you know 15 billion transistors on each
one of our devices uh it required a lot
of whales to die and people what are you
talking about well how do you think you
didn't design a computer using a
computer right the first computer was
not made using a computer the first
transistor was not made by making a
transistor the first computer program
was not written with another computer
program otherwise in other words things
have to come from more primitive more
basic more fundamental and Elementary
building blocks in this case we needed
to to you know burn whale oil to have
light in order to see to write down the
laws of thermodynamics uh we needed a
lot of billions and trillions and
trillions of tons of of Plankton to die
and descend to the to the bottom of the
earth to make a a lot of the petroleum
that we use to eventually maybe get to a
civilization that harnesses the wind on
its planet to harnesses all the sunlight
that falls on it um so that's a type one
civilization so it has a lot of
pre-existing technology we're nowhere
near that level okay we don't harness
all the energy available on the planet
as as an example um we could power all
of Humanity's energy needs by you know
by Plastering over you know Saskatoon
with solar panels with 100% efficiency
that would power the whole planet okay
or Alberta maybe let me just I'm I'm
tell I'm demonstrating how little I know
about provincial
geography Saskatchewan is the province
Saskatoon is the city so I was a little
yeah and it's not a very big city so I'm
thinking you're referring to the
province my PhD advisor PhD advisor so
my grandfather of PhD he did his
research in Saskatoon that's the only
reason I know about it okay so there are
a lot of I know Elon Musk Elon Musk
spent a bit of time here too
surprisingly so it is deeply connected
so let's get back to kardashev okay so
kardashev scale type two uh is is one
that's going to use all the energy
available from its star and this is
where my friend Freeman comes in to play
Freeman Dyson because he postulated that
to get to a type two civilization you'd
build a sphere around the star we're we
because of the inverse Square law which
sounds very complicated but it's not it
just means that light diminishes by a
factor of the distance squared so if I
move a factor of two away from these
these very expensive uh light bulbs that
I bought from Canadian preparedness.com
uh if I move away from that Distance by
a factor of two the intensity goes down
not by a factor of two by a factor of
four it's the same law of gravity and
and for similar reasons as it turns out
anyway that distance squared is what
causes the diminishing so you want to
capture the entire spherical area or the
area surrounding it the shell of light
that would create uh you'd make a Dyson
Sphere to do that and then a
civilization that's of type three would
do that for every star in the galaxy
that it inhabits so we're nowhere near I
think we're in like type zero uh we're
using a you know fraction of of a of of
a trillionth of a percent of the energy
just of our home planet let alone of our
star and let alone of our galaxy okay so
what about ferm's Paradox and the great
filter I think that's something you know
I I referred to earlier with respect to
okay are we going to destroy ourselves
before we get off the rock do we even
want to get off the rock you know if we
if we're going to create
metaverses and things which can simulate
a far more entertaining reality that is
out there in the cold Dark Universe will
we ultimately come to the realization
that space flight is feudal and just
wasteful and we're just going to stay on
the rock with our virtual reality
headsets uh do we get past the great
filter in your mind what are going to be
some of the the uh sticking points I
guess if you will and and potential ways
that we we might meet our demise so
enrio fery was one of the Titanic
physicists of all time he was one of the
last great people to understand
theoretical physics and also to
understand experimental physics so at
the University of Chicago where he was
working and where we now have fery lab
uh the first accelerators the first
nuclear reactors and F and the first
self-sustaining critical mass uh came
together as I said it was in the 30s and
40s and the reason that that's important
is what else happened what happened in
1947 well there's a Roswell crash and we
were getting to understand the
properties of of you know mechanics
better all these things came out at the
same time nuclear weapons first
sightings of you know claimed alien
craft uh quantum mechanics the Cold War
was beginning the end of the hot war was
beginning the Apollo Moon missions were
beginning the space race was beginning
all these are tied up and and the reason
I want to take that little detour is
just to say that well what if we're in
that same kind of an age right now it's
sort of feels like it doesn't it where
you think about how the universe is uh
kind of conspiring we have these Wars
hot and cold simultaneously we have
thoughts and claims of new physics we
have threats of war in the nuclear realm
we have biological War we have all these
different things I'm hopeful that as
that ushered in a golden age of space
flight of understanding the base layer
of physical reality of understanding
computation by the way came out of that
Alan Turing and and and so forth now
we're into the age of AI which we're
going to get into uh and actually
becoming an interplanetary species as
Elon Musk you know hopes to do and he
said that he hopes to die on Mars and I
hope he does too but just not on impact
I I really don't want that to happen to
the guy he's got more kids than you and
I combined so he's got to be careful I
think he loses track of how many kids he
has um and so he it causes him to make
new ones so I'm kind of jealous of him
but anyway um the the point being when
fery came up with this Paradox it was
based on the following type of
calculation which he was known for he
would ask his physics class he would say
something like this and and I would
might say the same to you anybody who's
watch how many piano tuners are there in
Saskatoon right now you have to think
about it you know maybe there how many
people have Pian how often do they need
to be tuned um you know what's the
what's the you know sustainable you know
rate of a piano tuner to keep his family
you know prepared with their preps and
their their Peak refuel and everything
else right so you'd have to go through
that calculation um and so he would do
that and he would train his students to
think physically and these are
theoretical physicist mainly so like he
was teaching people that are truly
esoteric brilliant brains much smarter
than
and he was teaching them to think about
physical reality such that not so they
can fix a toaster or call a piano tuner
but so that they could be more in tune
with what reality is presenting US based
on evidence then he asked the following
question how many um stars are there in
the galaxy and since then by the way
we've only this question has only become
more paradoxical on one hand but as I'll
point out uh I think there are very many
simple resolutions of which you
mentioned one of them already the great
filter we'll get to that okay so fmy
said said um take a the number of stars
that are like the Sun not too hot not
too cold last long enough so that
conscious beings can come into existence
to build technological um machines
robots and and Metallurgy so you need a
certain set of properties right you
don't have metalurgy underneath the uh
the Hudson Bay right you don't have
Metallurgy at the bottom of the marana's
trench you can't have a water world you
can't have an ice world you can't have a
pure desert World um so there are many
many uh compromises that would have to
be met in order for us to have the right
conditions to make a technological light
he wasn't concerned with you know where
is the um the yeast slime mold you know
from planet uh you know blon 7 he didn't
care about those because they're not
going to come to us um presenting us
with a paradox or fail to come to us
presenting us the Paradox as to why they
don't exist so he said take the number
of stars that have earthlike planets in
What's called the habitable zone where
you can have liquid water on occasion it
could be solid water I I've heard that
you sometimes get solid water up there
in maybe even this time of year but we
we'll see what happens so the uh the
existence of all those conditions then
you take how many stars there are in our
galaxy that are like that now multiply
that several of them we have you know
multiple planets that could either host
life right now and bodies I mean by any
Planet I could mean a moon of tit of of
Saturn or Jupiter any solid body that
has some liquid on it that also has a
crust that you could build technology on
okay and it turns out you say take maybe
there's 10 or 100 in our solar system
alone uh and then you multiply that by
the number of stars in our galaxy that
are like our sun not too hot not too
cold and you get an astronomical number
you get literally millions you know if
it's 1% of all the stars in the Milky
Way and each one has 10 planets you're
you're talking about 10 billion sites in
which life could exist in a
technological form not just slime mold
okay then he said well there's about
four or 500 of them that are within a
few hundred um Lighty years and maybe a
few that are within 10 10 or 20 light
years remember he's operating back in
1960 1950s so he's saying since we
turned on our first radio transmitters
in the 20s broadcasting our existence to
any alien species here we are either
it's a dinner bell either it's a warning
we can't say for sure what we're
broadcasting because we don't know who's
listening to it and at any communication
Channel you need to understand the
transmission and the receive receiver
just like with a walkie-talkie it
doesn't matter you have your
walkie-talkies from the store if I'm not
on the right channel it's totally
irrelevant you're just broadcasting into
the void so he asked the question with
tens of billions of potential places for
life of a technological sort to exist
how come no one's come to visit us and
that's the essence of fermes paradox now
is it a true Paradox like Zeno's Paradox
is it a mathematical conundrum with
potential mathematical resolution or is
it just kind of a curiosity it's not a
law of nature so after that in the 1960
a man by the name of Frank Drake who
sadly passed away last year he came up
with something called the Drake equation
the Drake equation according to him
parameterized the likelihood probability
and number of exoplanets of other
planets and technological civilizations
he became the the the basic you know
founder of What's called the SEI
Institute which stands for the search
for extraterrestrial intelligence
Institute is in Northern California um
these are legitimate hardcore physicists
these are people that are influenced by
great thinkers Carl Sean uh among them
was one of the great influences and and
Frank Drake as well again we want to
parameterize what we know about the
universe and since that time we've
measured how many planets there are the
number of planets went from one you know
where life uh where life could exist or
where we thought life could exist
hundreds of years ago and then 1995 it
began an explosion of exoplanet
discoveries made by various colleagues
and and and friends of mine and and so
forth leading to Nobel prizes for the
first time in true Astro uh searching
for extraterrestrial planets and so
forth so this is legitimate science is
not woo woo tinf foil stuff um but still
the question remains how come we don't
see them um and there are a variety of
reasons why we might not see them and we
can get into some of those reasons the
problem with those reasons is that often
we anthropomorphize them we say what
would obstruct us from getting to
another St star system could be
technological it could be pandemic that
causes our demands it could be a nuclear
war and there are some that say that
these civilizations don't exist for
ferm's question to be answered in the
affirmative that they are out there
because these civilizations destroyed
themselves and they reach what's called
a great filter there's some event that
causes the Suffocation the still birth
although it's long after our birth but
once you reach a certain level of
technological maturity of biological
complexity that things emerge viruses uh
you know and and so forth on the on the
emerging phenomena asteroid impacts on
the galactic scale uh all the way to
nuclear and in human-made or organism
made uh uh extinction level events so I
think it's it's fascinating to talk
about these things only in the past few
years would I say that these are out of
the realm of Science Fiction and into
the realm of true scientific fact um but
more than that they're really fun to
think about because the more we think
about them the more we learn about Who
We Are
we have to you know Elon tweeted you
know recently we have to pass the great
filter and some say if we discovered
extraterrestrial um intelligence that
would mean that uh we should be very
pessimistic about our survival which is
kind of weird right because uh
undoubtedly any technological
civilization that we discover is likely
to be much much more advanced than we
are and so it could be Discovery because
they're here to you know eat us or mine
our liquid water I I think those are
farfetched by the way but but the point
being that they've made it past the
great filter and we that means that we
still have to go through the filter that
means we haven't even we haven't even
gotone to the half Waypoint yet to see
where the filter could possibly be and
so that's a terrifying thought right um
but it could also be a hopeful one when
you think about how many people live
before you if you ever think about like
how many grandparents you have how many
great-grandparents how many go back
thousands of generations and think
that's only the tip of the iceberg we
think there could be in a very basic
scenario some people like will mccal and
others have calculated you know we could
live for like a trillion Generations um
or not not a trillion Generations but
there could be uh effectively the upper
limit on the age of the universe could
you know sets the actual limit for how
long a civilization could live and how
many generations could fit in there that
that's an absolute upper bound um not
that one that I take seriously but but
thinking for the long future I think it
is useful to think about these things